yeah you got to break down the haircut
man
so you got
i've been to a barber battle before
so you and your boy got the lines so for
people who are not hip to
what's going on with the line across
your because you got a real chiseled
hairline but it's also like
drawn in yeah
educate us educate me and the rest of
the white people watching this who are
[ __ ] disconnected oh [ __ ] think
this [ __ ] chalk forever for the most
part but it's not it's like a barber
principle that make the haircut like
pop out more [ __ ] but we started a whole
trend in the city where like we got all
the kids on it should they be putting
flour on the head and all that type of
[ __ ] but flower like that you bake with
yeah bro white flour all types of [ __ ]
like really crazy oh yeah that shit's
wild right so would you cause i've seen
i've seen this before but like i've
never seen like an artist really pop it
off so like would you say you're kind of
trying to set that trend yeah yeah oh
yeah everything market everything will
mark everything marketable i'm trying
the world on this [ __ ] um